[Music]
we are still patiently waiting for
Avengers infinity war to come out in 16
days ever since the movie was announced
there have been several theories and a
lot of people speculating on what we'll
see in the new infinity war movie I did
a video a couple of days ago talking
about those theories and talking about
whether they could be true or not but
there are so many theories out there
right now that one video just wasn't
enough so here's infinity war theories
part 2 some of these theories are pretty
good and some of them made us laugh so
if you want to join us in having a laugh
please hit that subscribe button to
start off with theory number one we
found the soul stone this theory states
that there are two Infinity Gauntlet
because in Thord the original we see the
Infinity Gauntlet in Odin's trophy room
with all of the Infinity stones in it
this is a good theory a good catch for
those of you who caught it and thought
it but of course it is a fake and that
has been confirmed in thor ragnarok by
hella bank fake week not to mention we
definitely know where all the Infinity
stones are from step four the soul stone
and they are not all together in the
Infinity Gauntlet theory number two
vision dies when the mind stone is
removed from his forehead this is
possible but I do not believe that it
will happen
what kinda is the most technologically
advanced country in the MCU and they are
where vibranium comes from vision is
made out of vibranium I'm guessing that
Sheree somehow finds a way to remove the
mine stone from vision or maybe Thanos
or something from the black order gets
the mine stone and then they bring
visions body to Sheree and she figures
out a way to kind of sustain and keep
vision alive I think a vision is going
to die it's going to be by some sort of
sheer force like Thanos knocking him out
or someone from the Black Order
physically killing him not from the mine
stone being removed Theory number three
Thor makes a new mule NER this is not
true Thor makes Stormbreaker well he
makes what they're calling Stormbreaker
it looks a lot like ultimate mule near
but call it what you want they're
calling it Stormbreaker call it a new
meal NER up to you
theory number four and this is something
to think about during them before is
that dr. strange will make team Groot
age this makes a lot of sense and is
very very possible the Avengers are
going to fight Thanos they're going to
need everyone in their top a condition
and that means maybe pushing Groot up a
few years of age and pushing them up in
maturity
theory number five Peter Parker develops
spidey senses I'm not sure if he
developed some or he already had them
and they just haven't shown us in either
movie that he's been in but it's clear
from the trailers he does speaking of
good ol spidey theory number six says
that Peter will receive the symbiote
suit this theory has actually been shut
down by Sony themselves they came out
and said that this film will not tie
into venom theory number seven and this
is kind of far-fetched to me but I see
it
The Scarlet Witch will turn evil
although I don't think it's going to
happen in the MCU in infinity war even
just for I can see it happening because
I can see evany MA or Thanos using the
scarlet witch's own powers against her I
can also see vision being captured and
being threatened to be killed unless the
Scarlet Witch goes against the Avengers
again I don't think it's very likely
that this will happen but I can see how
it could Theory number eight and you've
probably heard this one
it states that everyone will die very
very unlikely sure there are some
characters that are going to die but
there are also many characters that have
their own solo films coming up pretty
soon the only exception to this is that
maybe somehow the Infinity Gauntlet will
bring them back or Doctor Strange but
the time stone will bring them back but
this will still require at least one
person to be alive but speaking about
Doctor Strange and bringing people back
to life theory number nine is that
Doctor Strange will bring all of the
Dead back
Doctor Strange is arguably one of the
most powerful characters in the comics
and in the MCU but I'm still not even
sure if this is possible for him to do
we've haven't even seen it in the comics
unless you count him turning his dead
brother into a vampire which hey maybe
that's the title of Avengers 4 and
that's what's gonna happen I mean just
for vampires attack I think if anybody
is going to revive anybody I think it'll
either be done by the Infinity Gauntlet
or it will be done by Scarlet Witch like
she does Hawkeye and Quicksilver in the
House of M comic storyline Theory number
10 every villain that was killed by an
infinity stone will come back I don't
see this happening I think this theory
actually came from the theory that Red
Skull will appear in Avengers infinity
war end of it just for if this is true
then Red Skull will come back and run
as well but I do not think it's true
Thanos is out to balance the universe
meaning he's going to wipe out half of
the universe
I don't think bringing people back is on
his list of things to do right now and
one last bonus theory theory number 11
Thanos is doing this all for death this
isn't really a theory this is how it is
in the comics and the comics Thanos is
desperately and madly in love with a
lady death lady death is the actual
personification of death and she gets
really sad and frustrated that there are
more people alive than there are dead
and of course Thanos being madly in love
with her sets out to balance the
universe to me this will definitely be
in the MCU whether it's an Avengers
infinity war or Avengers 4 or even after
it will definitely be brought in if
you're unsure of this go take a look at
the post-credits scene in the first
Avengers movie The Avengers have just
defeated that Chitauri and thanasis
servant is speaking to Thanos in which
he says to challenge them being The
Avengers is to court death now if you
didn't know that Thanos was in love with
death when you saw the scene the first
time it probably just seemed like if
Thanos wanted to attack the Avengers
they would kill him but that is not what
this is saying this is saying that if
Thanos wants to impress death what she
does cuz he's madly in love with her he
will challenge the Avengers and you can
just take a look at that big old grin on
his face telling us that he will and now
we're at Avengers infinity war well
that's it for all the theories in this
video I hope you enjoyed them and I want
to know what you thought about them and
if you have your own theories let me
know in the comments I'd love to hear
them be sure to give this video a like
and be sure to subscribe to my page if
you want to hear more theories about
Avengers infinity war and to join the
wolf gang thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was awesome